[Music]
[Music]
what a fun performance and the masked
singer is the joy and the fun that we
need hi guys it's Dedra bang car hey
guys I'm Kylie okie and you know we host
unmasking the masked singer every week
here at ET online and you might notice
we're not in our studio I'm at called
charlie is at home sitting on the floor
in my bedroom and we're in salt you know
quarantine right now like the rest of
the world it's a very strange time where
we're dealing with a global pandemic and
times are weird and we feel it's
important to be bringing joy to the
world however we can and the masked
singer certainly does that for Charlie
and for me I know that and despite the
weirdness we figured we would still
continue on and do this show we saw your
messages we appreciate that you guys
watch with us every single week so we
are here to talk about the masked singer
to do more evidence and clues and to let
you know who what home tonight yes we
are well the first performer is sadly
extinct yet again take a look at the
t-rex
[Applause]
shoujo see wha our girl or girl the
queen of dancing chaotic energy YouTube
and slime it is Jojo see why I had to
wear this shirt
the queen of bows I really you know like
I said it week one I'm such a fan of
Jojo and I think her doing this show was
such a smart move because the the
youngsters of the world really know who
she is like a lot of my friends who have
kids the kids are obsessed with Jojo but
a lot of people our age are not terribly
familiar with her despite her having
like global global super stardom and
success and I know that she wants this
big music career and I think doing this
show the world a different side of her
what did you think I did love how Jenni
actually pointed out the clue that you
referred to last week or believe I might
have been the first week event about the
slime with Northwest compared ahead and
how that was a dead giveaway for her so
the judges are on the same wavelength as
us here with guessing it was Jojo and I
believe it was two of them to pull and
Jenny who both locked it in as Jojo see
wah and and look I know you on a
personal note you are a die-hard
Pussycat Doll Stan of course so I'm sure
you had a complete meltdown when you
watch this performance and you got your
silver lining I got my silver lining I
actually Tex you just weak and randomly
I was listening to the song Jai Ho and
said why did this never win a Grammy I
stand by my statement but I am very
jealous and Jojo see why because she had
a special moment with Nicola after the
unmasking singing with her check it out
[Applause]
all right so we said goodbye to the
t-rex but of course we've still got
three remaining contestants who are
moving on to the super 9 of course
Charlie I will be here next week to give
you guys all the goodness as we kick off
these super 9 championships and stay
tuned to the end of the episode because
we also have a little interview from
last week when two Swan aka Bella Thorne
who was voted off but before we get into
all of that Charlie take us into our
first performance tonight I have loved
the night angels since week one and
tonight she has a shouting for more take
a look you know you make
all right let's just go back to basics
week one we called it kandi Burruss from
The Real Housewives of Atlanta now in my
mind I'm sticking with it all the way
through here a hundred percent and if
you needed further proof of course we
got a brand new clue package tonight it
was actually really cute it was the
night angels friend from high school who
shared some insight of their friendship
and what the night angel went through as
a young student who was also pursuing
this massive career as a singer and the
first dead giveaway to me was this whole
story that the friend told about how the
night angel didn't get to go to prom but
insisted on going to her highschool
graduation because she worked so hard
and even though the day that the high
school graduation was conflicted with a
gig that she was expected to be at she
was like I've worked too damn hard for
this I will make both happen and if you
go on Kandi's website she wrote this
whole story literally detailed by detail
in a blog post so the details of the
story just match up way too similarly
for it to not be kandi what do you think
it lines up in every way and then Shania
on top of that clue being a very solid
discovery for us to say it's candy we
got a new type of clue tonight so we saw
Valentine's a few weeks ago tonight with
the guest judge guest panelists will
arnett we saw them give a Lego related
clue to one of the judges that they had
to form a relationship with since for
this first one we saw the Lego go to
Jenny McCarthy and the Lego said good
times and the night angel told Jenny
that she says her name often on her show
well Jenny McCarthy obviously is known
for her Sirius XM radio show the Jenny
McCarthy show and she has had candy on
numerous times where they talk all about
the real hives housewives and her
relationships with those women and
co-stars so I think it's a dead giveaway
there I mean they're talking about candy
together
Jenny's friends with her I'm sticking
with candy here I just can't believe
that Jenny can't identify boys yeah yeah
yeah too funny but we're sticking with
candy for sure candy our next performer
how does how does pulling on the
heartstrings a little bit with this
out-of-this-world emotional performance
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
all right again we're sticking with our
original that the astronaut has to be
Hunter Hayes he has such a distinct tone
to his voice but even if you want to
look past the boys and dig into the
clues for more hard-hitting evidence or
research I'm gonna Pat myself a little
bit on the back like you like I cracked
the code on this one because a big woman
you figure it out I want to point out
this is a big one I hope that it's true
so you know all season they've been
giving us these stacks about how many
tattoos how many gold records how many
does help me die well they told us that
there was one person who holds a
Guinness World Record and I think we
finally found it in Hunter Hayes so the
package tonight we saw the dice they
were rolled on a ten it was a five and a
five the number 10 has a lot of
significance to Hunter Hayes because he
holds the world record for having played
the most concerts in the most cities in
a single day so in 2014 he played ten
cities intended sorry ten different
shows in ten different cities in 24
hours how is that possible I do not know
I do not know and that is Sam he is a
real OG if he was able to pull that off
and I think that that has to be him what
do you think I mean if he has that
stamina and dedication to do that many
concerts in that short amount of time he
can definitely be running around that
stage in an astronaut costume and I
think that's important so again the
onstage clue with the Lego so this one
went to Nicole and we saw the little
lego gift set it said mall on it and
then we heard the astronaut say to
Nicole
remember when we were both together
celebrating a huge birthday so
immediately I know we've of a thought
big momma that would make most sense who
rented out a shopping mall to celebrate
their birthday well it's not a shopping
mall celebrating the birthday was a
little different because Nicole
Scherzinger and Hunter Hayes actually
both performed at the Independence Day
celebration for the 35th annual a
Capitol fourth special on PBS this was
in 2015 and they were celebrating the
birthday of the country not a person
the country and on top of that the mall
not a shopping mall guys it's the
National Mall in Washington DC the area
of monuments and parks where this
celebration takes place that is also
some very very intense deep diving there
was math in this blue package you did
with the dye I'm doing some history over
here the astronaut is taking us through
every subject this season we do well the
Rhino is our next performer and listen I
know Jeter you have some very good
guesses I want to know what you guys
think but first take a look at the
performance you know weeks past I feel
you and I have struggled the most with
trying to pinpoint who the kitty is the
kitty is super difficult I think for
everyone across the board I think the
kitty is literally a walk in the park is
literally apple pie compared to the
Rhino the Rhino is impossible so you
know what do we do when something's
impossible we start asking for help so I
have I have outsourced my research
skills to my husband who is a die-hard
sports fan and I said you gotta help me
out do you have any you know words of
wisdom or guesses that come to mind and
he said you know he watched it with me
and he was like I think it could be
Barry Zito and you know what my reaction
was admittedly I love sports just not a
huge sports man I don't know a whole lot
about it and so my husband being such a
baseball fan he was like oh yeah he's a
a former MLB pro he played for the
Oakland A's he played for the San
Francisco Giants and he's also a singer
and a lot of these clues seem to match
him
so in tonight's clue package did you
notice in the map that was behind the
Rhino the state of Missouri was kind of
pulled out and they definitely had to
look up which state that was Charlie my
faith in your geography skills has to be
higher than that
well I knew it was Missouri I'm proud of
that so I started I started looking
online and it turns out Barry is now
married to a former Miss Missouri
amber sire they got stuff they got
engaged in April 2011 and they were
married later that year in December so
like a little crown on top of Missouri
obviously be king and queen marriage
exactly very easy though it's great and
like you know he's talked so openly
about having struggles at hitting low
lows and Barry actually wrote a memoir
not too long ago where he chronicled all
the the highs and lows the difficulties
that he's gone through in his life and
how much he's relied on his wife and how
big of a role she's played in his
success so I don't know between the
Missouri and and the highs and the lows
clue and the memoir I'm thinking it too
now Barry Zito what do you think listen
I had no idea so I took your advice I
you know and then I tried to apply the
clues to said Barry Zito
well the Lego clue that we saw was a
Lego little gift that to Robin we saw
the number 1,000 and then we heard the
Rhino say we are literally on the same
track so immediately I'm like okay we
think it's an athlete is it a track star
I don't know that seems like a stretch
but anything's possible with the show
and then I said no let's keep looking
and I actually found out that there is a
2012 movie called
1000 words starring Eddie Murphy I don't
think it's Eddie Murphy but on the movie
soundtrack there's the track there is a
song called lost without you written and
performed by Robin Thicke and there's
also a song called butterflies
co-written by Barry Zito you're gonna
get you're gonna get a little this is
our version of with you on the Barry
Zito train because I mean that that is a
very direct
yes and that was some deep research that
you did and look I'm a fan of it this is
Barry Zito I'm a huge fan the guy's got
an incredible voice at an incredible
story and I guess we'll see you next
week when we start to unveil Yoshi
before we get into that though guys last
week we had a really cool opportunity to
actually talk with the Swan aka Bella
Thorne though unveiled some secrets
about her experience performing on the
show take a look
could you help come up with all of the
clues in the clue package um yes and no
yes or no so it's definitely an
interesting experience so you have like
a really long interview over the phone
okay board fall disguised and whatnot
it's really interesting and you're
talking to a producer and your voice is
disguised yes Wow
secretive yeah it's really it's really
crazy it's it's like you're actually
like really I was kind of freaked out
with how seriously they they really are
taking it and like it's like really
serious yeah and then you do a long
interview and then you kind of you can
hear your clue package and then they
pick certain parts from your interview
for your food package and whatnot and
then you put that together yeah go and
then I think another funny thing is like
all day you're just learning facts about
your character like did you know that
swans fly at this did you know that
swans are super territorial did you know
that sois it's like you're just like
Swan facts like growing up Swan facts
what are you supposed to do with that
you're supposed to like um I think they
tell you so that you get in that like
them the heads - yeah yeah I have to
know if you would continued with the
show are there like songs that you had
on a list that you were preparing to
sing and to work on um yeah my next song
was gonna be changes by extension I
never say right I'm always scared not
saying it right and
I had some other songs picked yeah I was
gonna do the climb by Miley Cyrus can we
get that on YouTube or on your insta
story or something okay I just start
singing I'm like you know what since I
got kicked off the mass singer I do my
own live I love that she was willing to
open up about so much about doing this
show and I think that's the best part is
when they want to talk about all these
behind-the-scenes things that we don't
get to see his viewers and I would like
to personally go on the record and I
would still like to ask for Miley Cyrus
is the Cline I want it to we're all
sitting at home we've got our laptops
and not a whole lot to do so Bella
please give us the clients out on that
yeah moving forward for next week we now
officially have our super 9 finalists
from group a we have the turtle and the
kangaroo and the white tiger group B we
have the Frog kitty and banana and Group
C as of tonight we have the Rhino the
astronaut and the night angel and I am
so excited to see all of these 9 onstage
together Jenny McCarthy said tonight
that she thinks the night angel will
probably win the whole thing who is your
pick to take the whole thing home oh no
I do love the night angels sue she's
definitely at the top but I do think the
kitty if she keeps this identity
mysterious and we truly cannot crack it
it could be her - Wow I'm with you there
but I've got a real soft spot in my
heart for the turtle I do love the
turnoff
the colonel sang danced and you so did
the Frog there's so many talented banana
so much potassium guys don't worry we'll
be serving you lots of potassium and a
whole lot more next week we're gonna try
to keep doing this from home hopefully
you like it we're still so curious to
interact with you so we see all your
messages on social media please keep
commenting below let us know what you
think who you think is gonna take this
whole thing and stay safe or whether you
during this weird time line but we have
the best singer and we have each other
so I'm Deidre Behar I'm Charlie O'Keeffe
and we will see you guys next week bye
[Music]